nos internautes notre quatrième sujet ce
soir c'est la presse emmanuel macron a
fait hier une opération séduction auprès
des des journalistes ce qui n'avait pas
fait depuis un moment mais il n'est il a
peut-être le seul selon le baromètre
lacroix 40% des français portent un
intérêt faible voire très faible
distille à l'actualité et la réforme des
retraites dont les français cerne mal
les contours ne la zep à encourager l à
lacer leurs intérêts alors les médias
traitent ils bien des bons et des vrais
sujets on écoute les réactions de
plusieurs de nos confrères
il faut être beaucoup plus proche des
gens il faut être beaucoup plus alors il
faut être beaucoup plus indépendant à
l'égard de tous les gens qu'on peut
rencontrer les demandes de
hiérarchisation la formation puisque
d'entrée dans un paysage saturé donc si
on peut faire la part de l'important du
fiable et crédible du solide
on essaye via les réseaux sociaux de nos
de nos médias du d'intéresser les jeunes
à l'information que nous défendons c'est
à dire celles où il ya plusieurs sources
qui est vérifiée on n'a jamais eu autant
besoin de journalisme c'est ce que me
dit c'était une finale warhémois trouve
ça plutôt formidable jeu comme ça alors
génie bastié puisque vous êtes là
journaliste de ce plateau
dites moi ce que vous en pensez rassuré
comme on peut mais c'est vrai que c'est
un c'est une enquête qui est assez assez
perturbé
on peut seront peut trouver un point
positif c'est que la confiance remonte
légèrement sur la première fois depuis
longtemps ou en tête on avait atteint
aussi un fond mais je pense aussi que la
crise des gilet jaune a peut-être permis
une reconnexion aussi des médias avec le
quotidien des français peut-être
d'ailleurs une saturation ensuite on a
trop parlé d'un gilet jaune mais est
quand même
on a parlé d'une population au quotidien
d'une population qui était un peu en
dehors des radars médiatiques et ont
finalement on a répondu un peu aller à
l'idée d'une déconnexion d'un jean d'un
journalisme parisien etc etc
après moi ce qui me frappe c'est en
effet le désintérêt croissant de
des gens envers l'actualité alors est-ce
que c'est dû à une forme de saturation
après les présidentielles après les
gilet jaune et c'est une sorte de trop
plein ou est ce que c'est quelque chose
de beaucoup plus profond c'est à dire un
espèce de clairement d'individualisme
poussé à son maximum qui fait qu'on se
désintéresse des d intérêt de la chose
publique et moi j'ai peur en fait d'une
information à deux vitesses c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui que on soit dans une
espèce de pareilles de darchy paix
lisation du paysage c'est que chacun
regarde les médias qui les intéressent
et qui est une forme de journalisme à
deux vitesses c'est à dire d'un côté des
gens qui ont les moyens qui sont
surinformés qui font partie de l'élite
qui sont abonnés à des journaux qui
payent pour l'information et de l'autre
des gens qui finalement se nourrissent
de finalement de la formation sur les
réseaux sociaux qui est pas vérifié qui
est un peu le tout venant ou qui
finalement se désintéresse complètement
des enjeux politiques et sociaux et qui
créent et qui accenture est en fait
cette fraction entre l'élite et le
peuple est je pense un enjeu majeur oui
je vois précisé malgré tout que le
figaro offre à la fois les informations
gratuites qui sont extrêmement consulter
et des informations payantes en dons qui
ont de plus en plus de succès sébastien
pots de vin que les québécois ont un
concept d'infobésité plus la formation
et la est en fait plus on a du mal à
ingérer et avec notamment les chaînes
d'information continue on voit bien que
l'actualité
voilà on n'a des vers sur les diverses
quand on a presque 24 heures
de d'antenne par jour évidemment quand
on est obligé de revenir de multiples
reprises sur les questions d'actualité
déjà le cas sur ces gars là c'est bien
pour ça que le rire l'antenne
tranquillement et nous s'agit
d'améliorer la valeur donc ce concept où
il ya tellement de retours sur la
formation de réussite vous regarder les
chaînes d'information continue plus
d'une demi-heure en fait vous allez
avoir les mêmes thèmes beaucoup
évidemment ça peu fatigué ça c'est le
premier point ensuite
la question de la défiance la défiance
est là en direction de toutes les
institutions et les médias sont
considérés comme une institution souvent
considérés comme des institutions keith
hawton aux mains de grands groupes de
finance de grands capitaines d'industrie
excel etc et donc on se dit mais
l'information n'est pas bonne elle n'est
pas vérifiée que ces périodes il ya
cette notion de défiance est ce qui est
étrange c'est que plus on se dit ça pour
ce deal informations vérifiées plus
malgré tout les médias effectivement non
vérifiées par les réseaux sociaux
rapport de succès oui mais parce que
c'est un choix qu'on fait soi même je
vais sur les réseaux sociaux j'ai
l'impression du coup de pouvoir moi
naviguer tout seul je n'ai je vais pas
forcément penser que derrière tout ça il
ya des algorithmes qui vont proposer des
informations qui vont toujours avec dans
le sens de ce que j'ai déjà vu faisons
pas et ces terrains est un diamant etc
mais non il est peut-être mais en tout
cas on voit bien c'est à dire que trop
d'informations d'un côté le sentiment de
défiance et la possibilité de se tourner
vers les réseaux sociaux égale du coup
et bien forcément un retrait donc du
coup l'actualité on avait pu au niveau
de commandes hier de l'information mais
ailleurs je suis professeur à
l'université juste avec elle quand je
discute avec mes étudiants quand j'ai
mes questions aux canaux d'information
et vous seriez étonnés d'entendre que
dans les journaux de la presse nationale
s'est pas du tout là où ils vont se
renseigner en premier lieu 18 24 ans de
mémoire si c'est l'âge des étudiants ces
75 % via les réseaux sociaux sont pas
les réseaux sociaux ça peut m'arriver je
le confesse
on parle d'informations de presse c'est
la même chose et je crois que le premier
sujet là c'est à dire que ce qui la
presse a eu et avait une fonction
première qui est une fonction d'informer
or aujourd'hui vous pouvez être informés
de ce qui se passe on reviendra dans un
instant sur la nature de ce qu'on vous
dit sont passés par la presse donc il ya
pour moi depuis longtemps et la presse
française y est pas pour grand chose
parce que c'est un phénomène plus large
mais une question qui est posée au
journalisme c'est aujourd'hui quelle est
sa plus value par rapport à une
information vous achetez plus journal le
matin ce qui arrive et nous sommes tous
partis clairement jeunes donc à nos
grands parents mais pour savoir ce qui
s'était passé la veille
vous avez la capacité de viennent de le
savoir pratiquement en temps réel
donc la question qui est posée c'est à
quoi sert le journal et le problème
c'est qu'on est dans une société de plus
en plus désintermédiés dans lequel les
intermédiaires d'ailleurs sont toujours
montrés du doigt et jenny bastien qui
connaît bien ce concept de société
liquide je pense sera d'accord avec moi
à dire qu'aujourd'hui on est dans un
monde c'est peut-être d'ailleurs le
nouveau monde ou moins d'intermédiaires
mieux c'est parce que l'intermédiaire
est suspicieux et ça vaut d'ailleurs
pour les avocats comme la notaire comme
pour les journalistes comme pour les
élus locaux et les politiques donc les
nos concitoyens ont l'impression que il
faut pas qu'ils d'intermédiaire entre
une information ait eu comme il n'ya pas
besoin d'intermédiaire entre un
chauffeur de taxi et eux en l'occurrence
un beurre est donc cette
désintermédiation elle coûte aujourd'hui
à la presse et moi il me semble que il
faut pouvoir restaurer instaurer une
fonction à la presse qui nécessitent
peut-être que fa si la population qu'à
l'origine des faits news malgré tout est
exact mais c'est ça parce que si vous
voulez qu'on va c'est ce que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
les nouveaux étudiants ils vont aller
voir des informations qui sont sur des
canaux directs où ils auront l'illusion
que c'est ce n'est pas le goty paix le
figaro et libération
or en réalité il faut qu'à mon sens les
médias soient peut-être plus engagés ils
ont une responsabilité une
responsabilité évidemment social mais je
crois qu'il faut qu'ils assument aussi
leurs orientations politiques et qu'ils
assument aussi leur lot de leurs
nécessités de valeur ajoutée dans la
compréhension de l'information
d'une certaine manière je pense que le
figaro
aujourd'hui à plus d'avenir sur ses
pages payantes mais qui sont des
éléments d'analysé que sur
c'est pas gratuit qui sont des zones
manque d'information mais c'est un débat
objectivement intéressant et qui à mon
avis en reflets aussi de l'évolution
société qualité c'est un ensemble
oui je parcours souvent le figaro pour
connaître l'actualité ne supprimez pas
essayer de restaurer la confiance en
faisant la chasse est absolument en fait
nous partout et tout le temps et parfois
en passant des heures et des heures
c'est extrêmement chronophage à démonter
la moindre rumeur qui circule sur
internet
en effet il dit que ma ville voudrait
qu'elle seconde main sur le toit des
informations ces 84 secondes pour le
tour d'internet
non mais donc je pense qu'à aussi je
pense que c'est une erreur de certains
grands médias de se jeter dans la
vérification de tous tout le temps
évidemment il ya des sujets qui sont
intéressants à vérifier s'ils sont un
sujet d'intérêt public par parler de
l'aller déroute la réforme des retraites
etc
mais si si la moindre rumeur sur
internet on se met à la dignité etc
c'est un tonneau des danaïdes on ne s'en
sort plus et c'est pas ça qui restera et
restaurera la confiance royale et non
deux mois je suis pas convaincu que les
fêtes new soit un vrai sujet c'est juste
une aujourd'hui oui ça c'est vrai mais
c'est à l'accélération par le numérique
des rumeurs qui existe et que dans
l'histoire de la presse avant même la
presse on ait eu les libelles après on a
eu toutes les feuilles de chou qui
circulent dans tous les sens et et qu'on
a des et qu'on dénonçait ses sa a
diffusé des fausses informations
il ya un phénomène d'accélération de
cette diffusion jeu que montre aussi ce
sondage c'est que le média auquel les
français font le moins confiance c'est
les réseaux sociaux donc je pense qu'ils
savent encore hier à refuser la bonne
information
et effectivement je pense que s'ils
recherchent aujourd'hui c'est pas
d'informations on voit les lycées de
l'appeller de l'explication et c'est
probablement pour ça que tous les
journaux développe aujourd'hui des
analyses et qu'il ya même des tous ces
nouveaux magazines qui se créent d'un
avec en proposant un regard spécifique
une analyse plus dense pour apporter une
valeur ajoutée comme vous le disiez la
formation on a en direct en à moi
surtout que maintenant elle peut même
être générés par des robots donc c'est
ça appelle une reconfiguration de la
faute de la presse est probablement mais
là c'est moi mon domaine des mets du
métier des journalistes tel qu'il a
existé pendant la décennie de pluie dans
voilà on n'est pas dans le même ordre
d'idée on n'est pas dans l'anc est
l'analyse était à vous parler d'autre
chose finalement sur les sujets eux
mêmes est-ce que vous pensez que les
sujets sont pas les bons écoutez c'est
de dire quelque chose de très subjectif
pour ma part j'ai arrêté de regarder la
télévision à partir des gilet jaune et
je ne lis plus guère roman parce que
j'en apprends beaucoup plus sur la
société française en lisant des romans
qu'en regardant augmenter les
statistiques vous voyez donc oui
effectivement je ne suis pas captivé par
les informations qui tourne qui tourne
en boucle dans les airs exactement parce
qu'en même temps les gens aient envie de
voir ce qui se passe mais
je je pense qu'on a eu on a eu un
certain nombre de débats
sur des questions qui ne passionnent pas
les français savoir causé toute une
journée de débats pour savoir si oui ou
non il faut que les toilettes soient
mixtes franchement je pense que les gens
s'en fichent
alors voilà la réalité de leur quotidien
c'est d'autres problématiques et que
parfois effectivement il ya déjà on peut
ce passionné et compris sur les réseaux
sociaux d'ailleurs ces débats qui sont
pas les préoccupations quotidiennes des
français mais après c'est très facile de
parler des préoccupations quotidiennes
des français de manière générale comme
ça il ya une étude qui est sorti qui
montrait que les fausses nouvelles
mettez cette fois moins de temps pour
toucher autant de personnes que les
vraies nouvelles et pourquoi c'est le
cas pour pas parce que il ya marqué
fausses nouvelles dessus évidemment mais
parce que bien souvent quand vous
propagez elle vous êtes extrêmement
rentable financière quand vous propre
camp vous propagez des fausses nouvelles
vous êtes vous toucher aux sensations
c'est l'émotion à l'émotion et merci et
ce qui est sensationnel évidemment c'est
aussi un élément de marché serre que
plus c'est sensationnel plus vous avez
vous pouvez vous faire laïque et où vous
pouvez être plus et je crois que à la
question qui est posée c'est par le
fonds d'aidé des banques sujet il est
évident qu'il ya un système aujourd'hui
puisqu'on est sur la recherche du
sensationnel plutôt que d'en du
décryptage et le système des algorithmes
et des réseaux td oui mais sauf que vous
voyez un sujet l'émotionnel il est vrai
bien que
il ya notre attention parce qu'elle
attend région oui mais vous avez la même
chose sur bfmtv c'est à dire qu'au bout
d'un moment on va on va parler de ce
dont on parle parce que le sujet il est
non pas d'imposer à quelque chose alors
de toujours de hiérarchiser
l'information et il a en réalité de
pouvoir faire de l'audimat
donc le modèle même est un modèle qui
est un modèle compliqué sur les faits
politiques de cette news avait aussi des
études qui ont montré que les gens les
plus radicalisées aux élections
américaines étaient
les personnes les plus âgées qui n'ont
pas internet et donc en fait les faits
que nous lui aucun effet sur c'est
plutôt là pour le coup c'est plutôt la
télévision que les à radicaliser
voyez donc à mon avis c'était il ya un
effet mais il a il est je trouve trop
simple d'expliquer toutes les effets
politiques contemporains attention à ce
que ça donne après sert qu'à partir du
moment où plus aucune parole n'a de
poids tout s'écroule si vous êtes
professeur d'université et que vous fait
rembarrer par quelqu'un qui va avancer
une fake news ils ont expliqué c'est la
même raison de diverses blessures mais
tout ça il faut pas continuer à
accélérer la machine à décrédibiliser
alors que je suis entièrement d'accord
avec vous je vous remercie tous les cas
that être au chevet de notre métier
passionnant fait par des gens passionnés
merci beaucoup nous nous retrouvons ce
soir demain soir même heure sur point de
vue très bonne journée très bonne soirée
à vous tous
[Musique]